coffee or caffeine has a half-life
of about five to six hours in other
words after about five to six hours
fifty percent of that caffeine is still
in your system which means that caffeine
has a quarter life
of 10 to 12 hours so if you have a cup
of coffee
at midday it would be the equivalent of
you getting into bed at midnight and
before you turn the light out
you swig a quarter of a cup of coffee
and you hope for a good night of sleep
and it's probably not going to happen
but
even if you're one of those people who
says you know look i can have an
espresso with dinner i fall asleep fine
and i stay asleep so no harm no foul
that's not quite true either because a
cup of coffee in the evening
will decrease the amount of deep sleep
that you get deep non-rem
sleep by somewhere between 20 to 30
have percent done any research or do you
know of anyone that's done any research
sometimes what i'll find is if i try to
just
close my eyes for 20 minutes at 3
o'clock i don't necessarily fall asleep
like it and it's actually pretty rare
that i would get into a deep sleep
but you know i could be in that quasi
sleep stage but sometimes it's more just
i've just closed my eyes and and just
try not to think about anything major
politics the craziness of the world and
that in and of itself is almost enough
of a reset have they done any research
on that that just the process of just
20 minutes with your eyes closed and
maybe just getting into that initial
phase
could be enough yeah we have done uh
studies on that and that's exactly what
we're finding that
even that quiet rest where you have your
eyes closed and you're somewhat
disengaged now if you look at
the brain itself it's actually dipping
like a little beak into water
it's dipping itself and having a little
soup son of sort of sleep during that
time
most of that time you're not aware that
you're asleep because it's still lighter
stages of sleep but it can be
restorative it can have benefits for
your mood for your emotions
even some benefits for cardiovascular
health is it as
potent um as you know getting into sleep
no it's not but is it better than just
constantly trying to power through
and grab an another cup of coffee and
you know hope for the best
absolutely it's much better than that so
it's all a range i think there's a
gradient of different conscious states
that our brain goes through
and some of them can really be
beneficial doesn't have to all be about
sleep
all right so you mentioned coffee i
already showed you the coffee cup
i'm a coffee guy when i wake up in the
morning the first thing that i think
about is that cup of coffee sometimes
i'm thinking about it as i'm going to
bed the night before
and i probably have a second a second
cup most days
um am i doing something wrong here am i
overly caffeinating my brain am i
harming my sleep am i doing something
too
unnatural to my normal rhythm based on
what you just said you're not doing
anything
wrong and i would actually recommend
drink coffee
which sounds strange from someone like
me but when it comes to coffee
just like with drugs the dose and the
timing
makes the poison so first there are some
wonderful health associations
with coffee um and that is i think
very strong evidence by the way it has
nothing to do with the caffeine though
that the principal reason you get health
associations with a cup of coffee
is because the coffee bean contains most
of the antioxidants that people eat
or consume because our diets are not
particularly
enriched uh the way that we eat in this
modern era
in antioxidants and it's left to the
coffee bean the humble coffee bean
to carry the weight of most people's
antioxidant needs
so a cup of coffee or two cups of coffee
or even three cups of coffee
in the morning that's just fine try to
cut yourself
off after about midday for most people
and here's the the reason why
firstly coffee or caffeine has
a half-life of about five to six hours
in other words after about five to six
hours fifty percent of that caffeine is
still in your system
which means that caffeine has a quarter
life of 10 to 12 hours
so if you have a cup of coffee at midday
it would be the equivalent
of you getting into bed at midnight and
before you turn the light out
you swig a quarter of a cup of coffee
and you hope for a good night of sleep
and it's probably not going to happen
but even if you're one of those people
who says
you know look i can have an espresso
with dinner i fall asleep fine and i
stay asleep so no harm no foul
that's not quite true either because a
cup of coffee in the evening
will decrease the amount of deep sleep
that you get
deep non-rem sleep by somewhere between
20 to 30 percent
now for me to take away that amount of
deep sleep from you
i would probably have to age you by
about 15 years
or you could just do it every night with
an espresso
so i think you know i i want to be clear
here i am
i'm just a scientist and i'm not here to
tell anyone
how to live their life that's not my job
all i want to do
is you know give you the science behind
sleep and things like caffeine so that
people can make an informed
choice you know life is to be lived to a
certain degree
yeah so when you meet the people who are
like oh you know if i have a cup of
coffee after 4 pm
i'm up all night versus the guy that can
have the double espresso
at 11 is that partly just how they're
wired i mean is that just their
physiology
it is their physiology and in fact it's
their genes and we know these genes
there are
several different genes and it's if you
want to sort of
get a little bit nerdy it's called
cytochrome p450
and it determines the speed of breakdown
of essentially of the caffeine in your
system
now some people have a version of that
enzyme where they will break down the
caffeine very quickly
other people and unfortunately i'm one
of them have
a version of that enzyme where the
caffeine metabolism is very very slow
so if i have a cup of coffee at you know
a.m in the morning after waking up at
you know 6 30 or 7 in the morning
even that usually leads to me not having
a great night
of sleep so there are individual
differences and we understand the
genetic basis of those
what about some of the habits of good
sleepers one of the things that i've
been trying to do for the last couple
years probably about two years now is i
try not to bring my phone
in the bedroom so i don't want the phone
to be the last thing that i look at when
my head hits the pillow
and i don't want it to be the first
thing that i see when i wake up in the
morning
that's been pretty helpful for me do you
guys recommend certain habits or
or have you found that certain people
just have better habits
related to actually getting to that deep
sleep
yeah i think you mentioned a great one
here which is the phone
you know the invasion of technology into
the bedroom has been
a harmful influence on our sleep in the
modern era
and in a way though you know that genie
is out the bottle
and it's not going in anytime soon so
there's no point in me
necessarily saying you know it's got to
be a technology-free environment
what i would say though is you've
probably had that experience where
you know that you need to get up for an
early morning flight
or there's something that you have to do
ultra important the next morning
you know that that night of sleep is
just not going to be the best night
and it's almost as though if you've got
to wake up at five in the morning for
your flight
you wake up at 4 58 before your alarm
yep and the reason is because the brain
stays in this very
shallow form of sleep it's not very
restorative sleep
and it's a phenomenon that's called
anticipatory anxiety
in other words you know something is
upcoming and the brain
goes into almost this threat detection
state because of the anxiety
and your sleep is shallow for
understandable reasons
i mentioned this because having your
phone there
is a kind of diet version of that you
know it's sort of
anxiety light l-i-t-e yeah for the next
day
because you're you're right for most of
us and i've been guilty of this in the
past
you know the first thing that we do when
we wake up in the morning is reach
across and we swipe right
and we open up the phone and we know
that there is
waiting for us just a tsunami of anxiety
of emails social media it all comes
through
yeah and what that does is that it
trains your brain
to expect that type of anxiety jag
each and every morning and so when you
go to bed at night you're not going to
have that restorative restful sleep
the other thing with technology by the
way in the evening is that it causes
what's called sleep procrastination
it's a real thing where you know you're
perfectly tired you could fall asleep
but you have your phone there and you
think oh
i should just check facebook one last
time and i'm just going to order that
thing on amazon and
you know oh you know dave rubin i think
he had this great section i'm going to
watch the
and all of a sudden it's 20 minutes
later and you do that each and every
night it's like compounding interest on
a loan and it can really degrade your
sleep so
i would say the rule of thumb if you
want to try and hack that is
you can only use your phone in the
bedroom when you're standing up
and after about five minutes of doing
that you kind of
as soon as you sit down or you want to
lie down that's the time you've got to
put the phone away
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell